let me show you this book trailer
because i
again guys i pay a lot of attention to
body language and behavior
so this entire trailer
um
you can watch it on this channel let me
put it up here on the stream you don't
need to see the uh or hear the audio
but you know you get the ideas you know
he's doing this uh blah blah blah i've
got a new book you know the highlight
reel
you know him doing the book he did it
with mark manson apparently he's a i
mean he's a genuinely good good author i
mean you know he writes well some of his
uh
books aren't the greatest i mean some of
his advice on women kind of kind of
sucks if i'm being honest um where is it
here is that around 56 seconds i just
want you to watch this okay
pause okay
i'm just going to play this in slow
motion because it's a very slow clip
what everybody's doing here i'm just
going to back it up is they're basically
going like this
and they're just like mwah okay watch
what jada pinkett does
now remember this is will's moment this
is his book this is his story this is
his biography this is his big thing like
when you have a book trailer done
it's a big thing for you but just watch
what jada does
what is she doing over here what is this
can you guys see that
she's flipping the bird everybody else
is you know going with the the rhythm
love kisses is blowing stuff out like
that she's flipping the bird
another good thing that you should
definitely want to take a look at when
it comes to assessing situations like
this
i showed you guys the pictures of um
august and her
versus uh will
can i make this bigger
i'm going to lose some of these if i go
like that that's okay that'll fit
but just look at the body language here
camera camera this is this is a famous
one over here i'm sure you guys have
seen this one before
this where's that picture it's probably
scroll down a bit
no
come on
it's probably in a slide somewhere
i'll just go back over here this one
over here that that one there that i'm
talking about okay look at look at the
body language look at it
look at this
sizzle right here
make this bigger for you look at
this
can you can you like do more to put her
up on a pedestal
can you
i don't know that it's possible i really
don't know that it's possible that you
could potentially do more in a gala
event
dressed in the nines hey go look at her
and she's not even looking at the dude
she's not even looking at the dude
that is not the face of a woman that's
got genuine desire for her man
look at this one over here
she's not even looking at him she's
looking at the camera what i what i aim
to look for
if you're looking for genuine desire you
want that dirty sanchez look that she
gave to leonardo dicaprio you know that
look that i'm talking about some of you
have seen it some of you haven't i'm
going to cover it separately in another
video but that's that's the look that
i'm looking for do we have again over
here you know he's all over her
do we have any photographs
of jada
given the dirty sanchez will's all over
her wills all over her
she's even looking away from him
he's looking at her attentively she's
looking away from him
again over here again over here the same
pose right
and i present to you
i see nothing
nothing
you guys see it i don't see it again
over here he's all over her he's all
over her
i don't get it this is like will smith
okay he's an a-list actor
i am legend men in black
you know
independence day you can go right down
the roster he's done he's knocked it out
of the park
not on one or two movies but i would say
probably dozens
he's a multi-millionaire okay he's
probably worth at least
half a million
i'm not happy sorry probably close to
about
450 to 550 million dollars he's loaded
he's loaded
jada pinkett's a nobody she was
she was uh with with tupac
uh from what i understand she auditioned
to be will smith's girlfriend on the
fresh prince of bel air
but the uh
casting director didn't cast her
because she was too short they said for
him um so they didn't use her and they
casted somebody else but will went head
over heels for like the sympathy was at
the time he was married at the time
chased her down left his marriage ended
up marrying her and knocking her up
excuse me and by the way there's also
articles out there
on how jada regrets getting married
getting pregnant
and
was
i think the uh soundbite that i read was
pissed off that she had to get married
to him because you know she was knocked
up at the knocked up at the time i beg
your pardon
we got here in the chat some of you guys
are just going on i think men need to
learn to be
doormat seeing how father handles
situation i think men learn to be
doormats seeing how father handles
situations subconscious once a man is
hit in the face he learns better and has
let family base learning and miss go
the i
men
it's the same thing with women too but
but
folks learn from their parents okay
there's a lot of
ingrained learning that that happens in
your own household as you're growing up
watching the roles of those two people
rich were in the stories that jada was
alpha widowed by none other than tupac
shakur yeah that's correct um where's
that tupac thing i need to pull up here
it's there it is
this is what um moff was referring to
let me remove this
um
so this is his handwriting again i spent
way too much time looking at articles
and reading stuff but this is tupac's
handwriting here if you don't know who
tupac is get your head out of the
closet and go and get some of his music
okay
probably one of the most talented
rappers that ever lived
says over here you will never fully
understand how deeply my heart feels for
you i worry that will grow apart and
i'll end up losing you by the way this
is tupac writing for her this is not her
writing to him so this is a bit that
moth was talking about in the uh
comments about uh bringing the climax
without intimacy you bring me to climax
without intimacy and you do it all with
real grace you are my heart in human
form a friend i can never replace blah
blah keeps going but again look at the
body language like this is a woman here
that's been used her entire life
being showered
you know with attention by men
i don't i don't know that that she was
alpha widowed in the way that i thought
that she was initially now that i'm
reading some of the lyrics that tupac
wrote about her there was a few other
ones that came up as well where he
actually wrote songs and poems to her
um
obviously he was head over heels with
her
it seemed to me like it was mutual
was she alpha widowed
perhaps i don't know there's not really
too much out there on it to be honest
with you
um what's dylan got for us here
spiritual higher thinking has nothing to
do with our animal lizard brain which
handles genuine attraction it's like
trying to teach potato shakespeare
yeah that that that whole like new age
wussa
let's get our spiritual wussa on and you
know you go make yourself happy and i'll
make myself happy and we'll come back
together and we'll be happy let me play
this clip for you over here this is from
his uh social feed it's it's not long
it's only two minutes let me just cue it
up here and put it in the stream
uh stop share
tab
and see here you guys should be able to
hear this if you can't hear it let me
know turn up a little bit
and i asked her i said what did she
think was
you know one of the biggest revelations
that
she had had about love
she said that
you cannot
make a person happy
and i thought that was a real deep idea
you can make a person smile you can make
a person feel good you can make a person
laugh
but whether or not a person is happy is
deeply and totally and utterly out of
your control
i remember the day
um
i retired
i literally said to jada that's it
i retire i retire from trying to make
you happy
i need you to go make yourself happy and
just prove to me that it's even possible
and after we cracked the hell up
um
we started talking about we came into
this
false romantic
concept that
somehow when we got married that we
would become one
and what we realized is that
we were two completely separate
you guys hear a lot of this become one
oh two people become one you know you go
make yourself happy
let's just carry on finish this people
on two completely separate individual
journeys
and that we were choosing to walk our
separate journeys together
but her happiness was her responsibility
and my happiness was my responsibility
and we decided that we were going to
find our individual
uh
internal private separate joy
and then we were going to present
ourselves to the relationship and to
each other already happy
you guys hear the flaw in all this
we're going to present each other each
we're going to present to each other our
our new happy version of you ourselves
this is like you know the whole what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander there is no what's good for the
goose is good for the gander what will
should have done is said yo i'm the
fresh prince of bel air
uh i know i'm not tupac but i put out
some albums
and steam is picking up for me
i think he was about 27 or somewhere
between 27 to 29 when he met jada
his his career was on a roll okay he dug
her vibe fine he should have continued
on with his career dated her casually
left his marriage obviously because he
obviously wasn't digging that dated her
casually maybe spin plates
weigh out some options and then if you
wanted to invite her into his life
if she didn't have any red flags if she
didn't have any other problems then
maybe invite her into his life and have
some kids if that's what he wanted to do
but she is a compliment to his life it's
not like you go make yourself happy and
i'll make myself happy and then we'll
have some spiritual healing and some
wusa kombucha and we'll hold hands and
sing kumbaya and then everything will be
great while we go and pork other people
on the side and call it an open
entanglement
it's like how many times have you guys
heard me say men love to complicate
their lives and then justify why
i give you
will smith
okay he spent his entire life
complicating his life
and then trying to justify why he's done
it this is just a two minute click and
clip and this gives you a clear example
of it not coming to each other uh
begging with our empty cups out uh
demanding that she fill my cups in the
cup and demanding that she meet my needs
unfair and it is it's kind of
unrealistic
and
can be
destructive to
place the responsibility for your
happiness on anybody other than yours
you guys should know by now if you
followed me that you really don't want
to spend much time trying to make
anybody happy
let alone a woman it just ties in the
captain save a woman you know mentality
you know we've talked about that before
a lot of guys try to swoop in
oh she's a damsel in dis in distress i'm
going to put on my white knight armor
and i'm going to swoop in and save her i
want to make her happy
i'm going to do everything i can to
please her sexually and if i can't i
will off myself
i'm telling you man a lot of that
nonsense a lot of that nonsense
you